non c'est à dire que vous avez
en entrant en lançant le sujet on sait
dans la même phrase retour de la
fracture sociale et fracture
territoriale le pays il est multi
fracturée mais il est tellement multi
fracture et qu'en fait on peut plus
opposer un pays à un autre ça a pas
véritablement de sens c'est à dire que
il ya effectivement des difficultés
sociales intenses
elles sont certaines sont concentrés
dans les autres dans des endroits bien
identifiés dans les banlieues dans
certains territoires ruraux mais aussi
dans en plein coeur de certaines villes
donc la dimension territoriale de cette
fracture sociale elle n'est pas évidente
de la même manière il y a un sentiment
de crise démocratique de représentation
pour beaucoup d'habitants des
territoires non métropolitains mais ça
recouvre pas exactement la même
géographique et celle de la crise
sociale et donc quand on regarde le
résultat du premier tour par exemple qui
a vu la une du monde de lundi matin avec
une france face à face c'est une lecture
extrêmement simplifié qui est qui en
fait il résulte du fait qu'on a regardé
les cas les communes dans lesquelles
marine le pen arrivait en tête
beaucoup de communes rurales ça fait une
grande place et on a conclu que dans ces
communes dans lesquelles marine le pen
arrivait en tête
en moyenne elle ne fait pas plus de 30%
dans les territoires périurbains dans
les territoires autochtones dans les
territoires ruraux ni quoi que ce soit
30% c'est énorme c'est important c'est
et c'est grave mais c'est parce 50 ou
60% de la population est donc partout
ailleurs on a dans toute la france
manuel macro fait pas moins de 1% dans
les territoires ruraux
il fait pas moins de 1 % dans les zones
périurbaines donc en fait la question
qui se pose
elle est peut-être moins de d'opposer
les gens que de se demander comment est
ce que on rigole on résout ensemble
villes et territoires ruraux personnes
insérées et personnes en difficulté
sociale
comment est-ce qu'on résout ce défi de
créer de la richesse tous ensemble mieux
à distribuer mais la partager mais ça
c'est un autre problème pollution de
faire le constat de la fracture on voit
que la biographie du vote fn daniel baer
est extrêmement complexe est ce qu elle
comment on peut expliquer alors ce vote
protestataire si ce n'est pas cette
source de cette france périphérique wii
déjà enfin pour rebondir sur tout ce qui
vient dire fazeli enfin moi ce qui m'a
frappé dans votre premier reportage là
c'est qu'il ya deux façons de dire la
fracture on dit fracture territoriale
met la première carte que vous avez me
montrer c'est une facture géographique
entre en gros l'est et l'ouest de la
france
et puis ensuite dans le propos du
journaliste et puis dans ce qu'on entend
aujourd'hui il ya plutôt une fracture
territoriale en strates les grandes
villes contre le rural contre les villes
moyennes contre eux ce qu'on appelle la
france préfère c'est pas du tout la même
chose
or autant c'est vrai qu'il ya quand même
aujourd'hui tendanciellement du point de
vue des inégalités sociales et
économiques plutôt une fracture entre la
france de l'ess la vieille france
industrielle et la france de l'ouest
autant la différence entre les strates
elle prête à une lecture très politique
qui oppose de deux fractions de la
société française d'hier les élites
contre le peuple les élites
métropolitaine contre le peuple rural et
je crois que celle là elle est
complètement fausse
elle est complètement fausse et je vais
pas reprendre ce que vient de dire
frédéric dire qu'en effet il ya
aujourd'hui autant de gens qui votent
parisot dans les métropoles dia il ya
trois métropoles 3102 métropole clients
qui ont voté qui ont classé en tête
mélenchon est étroit et trois métropoles
de nature complètement différente
marseille toulouse et lille il ya plus
de la moitié des villes moyennes qui ont
voté qui ont mis en tête le pen est ce
que c'est moi qui ont mis un terme à
cran donc voilà on ne peut pas opposer
derrière la fracture géographique on en
fait une fracture sociétale et je pense
que c'est faux et du coup enfin moi je
pense que ce qui explique en partie ce
vote
tuto protestataires dans les territoires
ruraux ville moyenne etc
c'est c'est pas la mondialisation et ont
dit les victimes de la mondialisation
moi je je distinguerai la mondialisation
de la globalisation la globalisation
c'est ce qu'on vit tous les jours s'est
passé quelque chose qui nous vient de
l'extérieur et qu'on subit la
globalisation c'est ce qu'on ait fait ou
les tous quand on passe d'un mode de vie
qui était le mode de vie locale en
bassin de vie etc en plus tôt on habite
en un endroit l'an de consommer un
ailleurs etc et donc on globalise notre
pratique du territoire et du coup il me
sens que dans les territoires de la
france dit périphériques les derniers
territoires ruraux dans les territoires
des villes moyennes
mais c'est là qu'il ya le plus grand
écart entre le mythe qu'on a mais la
france des terroirs la france des pays
enfin cette france des bassins de vie
etc
et puis la réalité que les uns et les
autres on fabrique ou en fait on vit
plus en bassin où vit en archipel et
donc du coup c'est ce décalage et il
semble qu'ils fait une des facteurs
explicatifs du vote front national c'est
qu'il ya une forme de souffrance et
c'est un politiste bruno latour qui
dégaine souffrance spatiale des français
moi je pense que c'est pas complètement
faux la souffrance spatiale c'est c'est
le fait qu'on qu on nous reconnaît plus
les territoires dans lesquels on vit
stéphane c'est qu'est ce que on a quand
même le sentiment si que marine le pen
s'est appuyé justement pour préparer
cette élection présidentielle sur ces
deux travaux d'une france oublié ce sont
des territoires qu'elle a
particulièrement ciblé ce qu'on peut
quand même et en tenir compte pour
expliquer les motivations des électeurs
frontistes hurel a labouré toutes ces
terres et on s'adressait à des
catégories sociales très typés et bien
sûr mais est là et c'est un salut c'est
une bonne nouvelle pour le front
national
et c'est aussi le signe que c'est un
parti qui s'installent définitivement
alors ça fait 20 ou 30 ans qu'on dit que
le front national s'installe bien sûr
mais élection après élection type de
scrutin après scrutin
on se rend compte que ce n'est plus un
parti de bastions ya encore quelques
années avant les européennes de 2014 et
les élections régionales et
départementales de 2015 on roule front
national était fort très fort dans
certaines zones le pourtour
méditerranéen l'est de la france est pas
nouveau ça date pas de cette année
en revanche maintenant quand on regarde
le fonds national marine le pen arrive
en tête dans 17 min commune alors
évidemment ce sont souvent des petites
communes mais c'est considérable et on a
bien constaté en 2000
il n'y a plus de terre de mission pour
le front national là où ils étaient
faibles extrêmement faibles si ce n'est
insignifiant
je pense notamment à l'ouest de la
france à tout l'arc atlantique descendre
la vallée de la garonne et on est le cas
cette année évidemment avec des scores
fleuves dans certains petits villages ou
dans des petites villes
je pense notamment la bretagne a encore
quelques années dans les villages
bretons dans les petites villes
bretonnes
le front national faisait 2 3 4 5 %
aujourd'hui l'eau fait de 10 à 20 et ça
vaut pour les petits type pour les
petits villages
ça vaut aussi pour les communes de
taille intermédiaire donc ce n'est plus
un parti de patience pour ça que je
parlais de très bonnes nouvelles pour le
front national parce que pour un parti
pour arriver en tête à certaines
élections intermédiaires comme pour être
qualifié pour le second tour on ne peut
pas se contenter d'avoir des points de
force dans certaines catégories de
français
que ce soit des catégories sociales ou
que ce soit des zones territoriales il
faut être bon partout
emmanuel macron il est fort partout
marine le pen aujourd'hui à quelques
rares exceptions près comme les centres
villes des villes riches on va dire pour
faire ça elle est forte partout sur
cette histoire du travail du fn sur le
terrain je pense que cette élection elle
est aussi elle s'inscrit dans ce qu'on a
vu au moment des municipales de 2014
dans ce qu'on a vu au moment des
régionales de 2015 c'est-à-dire
l'effondrement sur soi total des partis
classiques du gouvernement et les
républicains quelles que soient leurs
noms successifs où le parti socialiste
et quand on analyse les travaux que
réalise des géographes les sociologues
électoraux qui ont travaillé notamment
sur le travail du duché par les
militants front national en normandie
etc
c'est un parti qui travaille beaucoup et
donc qui travaillent là les gens mais
qui travaille aussi la question de la
crise démocratique dont les autres
partis s'affranchissent très largement
ils considèrent pour beaucoup que la le
gain électoral il se fait dans un très
joli programme et la désignation elle se
fait entre au sein de l'appareil
je veux pas dire que le front national
fait pas ça mais il se trouve que le
front national fait un travail de
terrain intense et on a vu dans la
campagne de mélenchon notamment qu' une
partie de
scor est sans doute dû au fait que il ya
eu un travail de terrain sur internet
est en réalité dans le terrain physique
que les autres partis ont eu plus de
difficultés à faire pour plein de
raisons mais sans doute aussi par un
espèce d'atavisme d'appareils on voyait
dans le reportage daniel verdes de
monnières souci on entendait françois
hollande défection qui réfutait cette
notion de france périphérique et
pourtant je rappeler un cette
interruption ce retour de cette notion
de fracture sociale dans le discours
notamment d' emmanuel macron hier arras
est ce que ça veut dire aussi qu'il ya
quand même des politiques successifs qui
ont échoué à la résorber cette fracture
sociale c'est clair qu'aujourd'hui on
est on est confrontée à une
multiplication des fractures et qu' on
ne sait pas les résoudre pourquoi on
sait pas les résoudre parce que on les
traite
j'irai à la fois successivement c'est à
dire que il ya eu quand on évoquait tout
à l'heure jacques chirac étant la
fracture territoriale
la superposition fracture sociale
fracture territoriale c'était plutôt au
sein des villes c'était la crise des
banlieues
donc on a eu un long moment où on fait
la fracture elle était focalisé à cet
endroit là puis ensuite on a dit la
facture entre la france de métropole et
la france périphérique et donc à chaque
fois on change et on y ait une espèce de
course poursuite à dire où seraient les
victimes de la mondialisation il me
semble que du coup on a une difficulté à
penser à la fois la globalité du
processus de deux de déstabilisation que
produit ce que j'appelle moi encore une
fois la globalisation plus que la
mondialisation et deuxièmement a inventé
les modes de traitement différencié de
ces situations se faire que par exemple
quand on dit parler de la vallée de la
garonne quand on dit voilà les zones de
votre front national sont les vols sont
les zones de forte densité du chômage
oui mais les cesser cette forte densité
du chômage et correspond pas aux mêmes
réalités et aux mêmes explications et
donc comme un traitement en termes de
politiques publiques cercle quand vous
prenez en gros le même par exemple la
densité du chômage dans le nord-est de
la france et la densité du chômage dans
le languedoc-roussillon vient en fait
c'est pas du tout même chômage d'un côté
c'est un chômage dans le nord-est c'est
un chômage
j'irai d'enkystement c'est des gens qui
peuvent pas en sortir quoi qu'ils sont
assignés à résidence
le chômage du languedoc-roussillon c'est
strictement l'inversé un chômage
d'attractivité sert les gens viennent
parce qu'il ya un espoir avec le soleil
et c' est qu' ils sont déçus ils sont
déçus parce que ils trouvent du boulot
mais il trouve pas du boulot pour le
couple et ils se retrouvent avec l'un
des membres du couple
et puis du coup difficultés d'accession
à la propriété etc ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que les modes de traitement
par les politiques publiques doivent
être différenciées
c'est ça qu'on sait pas faire c'est que
soit en ligne hi fi c'est ce qu'on a
fait récemment face qu'à françois
hollande quand il a dit voilà il ya une
seule géographie prioritaire de la
politique de la ville de la seine saint
denis à guéret soit on fragmente mais on
ne sait pas penser la différenciation
des politiques publiques à l'orias
hédiard ça en germe dans le discours de
d'emmanuel macron qui commence à dire il
faut traiter de manière différenciée les
situations mais on sent que c'est ça le
défi est ce qu'on va être capable de
penser la la la la multiplicité des
situations de fragmentation que produit
la globalisation et les pensées donc du
coup avec des stratégies d'action
publique différencier est-ce que vous
avez étudié cette question de la
fracture sociale notamment dans les
intentions de vote dans les ressorts et
bien des électeurs
oui bien sûr c'est ce qu'on nous appelle
la sociologie des électorats interrogés
toute une série de français qui se sont
prononcés dimanche dernier où d'autres
qui se sont abstenus d'ailleurs et on a
croisé tous ces résultats par leur
profil sociodémographique et par leur
profil politique ce qu'on fait à chaque
élection il ya des choses qui sont
persistants par rapport à ce qu'on avait
pu observer mais qui sont encore plus
fortes très nettement marine le pen est
très largement en tête dans l'électorat
ouvrier mais aussi parce qu'on en parle
moins souvent l'électorat employés très
souvent du vote ouvrier oui les employés
sont plus nombreux que les ouvriers
aujourd'hui et c'est au sein de ces deux
catégories
quelques elle enregistre ses meilleurs
scores c'est d'autant plus intéressant
cette année encore qu'il y avait jean
luc mélenchon qui avait une autre offre
neuf de gauche radicale qui en tout cas
si on regarde l'histoire politique
récente était censée répondre aux
aspirations de ces catégories ça n'a pas
été le cas
j'en ai eu nos chances qu'on obtient des
bons scores évidemment auprès de ces
catégories mais c'était en tout cas bien
moindre que marine le pen
mais là encore évidemment marine le pen
elle est plus faible on va dire chez les
cadres chez les cadres supérieurs mais
ce serait une erreur de dire que marine
le pen est la candidate des pauvres et
que des qu'emmanuel macron du candidat
des riches du ce
de l'établissement de tout ce que vous
voulez c'est totalement faux bien sûr
que vous près des cadres supérieurs
urbain des centres villes des grandes
villes elle enregistre des faibles
scores mais dans toutes les autres
catégories ce qu'on appelle nous les
catégories intermédiaires des cadres de
maîtrise auprès des fonctionnaires
auprès des salariés en général à
n'enregistrer score tout à fait
honorable pour elle en tout cas et qui
sont au dessus de sa moyenne nationale
de 2 22%
c'est ce que disait tout à l'heure elle
n'a plus de zones de faiblesse à part
quelques petites niches mais qui ne pèse
pas beaucoup et à ça et pour revenir à
cette idée de fracture sociale ce qui
compte le plus au delà des éléments
objectifs comme sa profession ou son
niveau de revenu c'est le moral des
français ya une vraie peur du
déclassement et tous les gens qui
considèrent que leur profession est en
déclin
tous les gens qui considèrent que les
générations à venir que leurs enfants
vivront moins bien que aujourd'hui tous
les gens qui considèrent qu'ils ont des
fins de mois difficiles ce sont des
questions qu'on a également posé dans ce
type d'enquêté est bien massivement
entre reporter leurs intentions de vote
sur marine le pen au premier tour et on
fera le se livrera au même exercice au
second tour et les chiffres que nous
publierons se croiront autrement plus
est remarquable quelque part parce que
là pour le coup sera pas 30 35 ou 40 %
qui ont voté pour moi une le pen ce sera
50 55 ou 60 % quelle que soit l'issue du
scrutin
mais il ya des catégories où elle sera
très nettement majoritaires difficile
par une réflexion binaire comme ça en
disant ce que rappelle stéphane lauzon
stig marine le pen quand date des
pauvres emmanuel macron candidat des
riches mais pourtant il ya quand même ce
discours très ciblé un de la candidate
frontiste à cette france invisible on
l'a vu encore hier avec la séquence
auprès des ouvriers amiens aujourd'hui
elle s'adresse aussi aux pêcheurs elle a
compris dans cette campagne d'entre deux
tours qu'il fallait quand même cibler
ces personnes qui se sentent des classes
et comme le rappelait ses fans des
moustiques c'est à dire que c'est tout
problème
de ce discours sur la fracture
évidemment qu'il faut la traiter sauf
que aggravé le constat miser sur le
constat qui a une opposition ça fait le
jeu
deux fêtes de marine le pen parce qu'en
fait pour construire une société dans
laquelle les gens en confiance les uns
dans les autres et et ça et que ce soit
pour la création de richesse pour tous
la création d'associations pour de
l'initiative individuelle ou collective
on a besoin de confiance on a besoin de
pas avoir peur de l'autre si enfin pour
faire ça tout ce qui va nourrir le
sentiment que l'autre est un ennemi que
les riches sont pas bons pour les
pauvres et que les pauvres sont des
menaces pour les riches tout ça ça
détruit delà de la la ça détruit l'an
commun qu'on a dans ce pays
et de fait il ya des partis politiques
dont le front national qui prospère sur
cette déprime collective donc faire le
diagnostic hâtif que la france est
coupée en deux de fait mais sans faute
au long de l'année elle m'a parlé de
l'apartheid social est nico territoriale
il faisait aussi en quelque sorte ce
constat ouais c'est pas pareil de dire
qu'il ya des zones qui sont dans une
très grande situation de difficulté
quand il parlait de l'apartheid social
dans les quartiers
quand vous allez dans le quartier
aujourd'hui vous vous rendez cannes bien
compte qu'il ya plein d'endroits en
france dans lesquels il n'y a pas la
même égalité d'accès à l'école n'y a pas
la même égalité d'accès à l'emploi n'y a
pas la même égalité d'accès à la culture
il n'y a pas donc
c'est pas c'est pas un apartheid au sens
où il y en avait 1 année en afrique du
sud
mais de fait il ya des quartiers où pour
une raison d' adresse pour une raison de
couleur de peau pour une plein de
raisons différentes diverses et variées
vous n'avez plus accès à la république
est donc le mot de manuel valls était
sans doute très fort mais c'est pas
pareil de dire qu'il ya des zones qui
sont dans une difficulté parce qu'elles
sont traitées différemment que de dire
il ya une france et 50 mètres derrière
france et une métonymie la france c'est
50% de français qu'on dira c'est à dire
vous avez 30 millions de français qui
sont prêts à se mettre sur la figure
avec 30 millions d'autres c'est pas tout
à fait tout à fait la même chose que je
veux dire on a un problème d'action
publique fort parce que des parties du
territoire des zones rurales ou des
quartiers en 18 des quartiers populaires
n'ont pas accès aux mêmes droits que les
autres et après se pose une deuxième
question qui et comment est ce que en
opposant les zones métropolitaines et
les zones rurales
de fait à mon avis on fait en et les
fossoyeurs de des zones rurales parce
qu'elles ont besoin des zones
métropolitaines
on est aussi les fossoyeurs des zones
métropolitaines parce qu'elles nous ont
besoin des zones rurales beaucoup plus
qu'elle ne le pense et elles ne se
rendent même pas compte que en dix ans
en un récent aux zones rurales un
discours sur le mode mais arrêtez de
vous plaindre on crée de l'excédent dans
les zones urbaines dont vous bénéficiez
on a un discours de charité bien
ordonnée dont le pays auxquelles le pays
est allergique depuis 1789 enfin là
l'idée qu' on n'est pas un livre de 2 de
son destin ça hérisse le poil de tout le
monde dans ce pays et donc on peut pas
tenir un discours aux territoires ruraux
quand on est une grande métropole 2 sur
le mode mais rassurez vous tout va bien
se passer pour vous parce qu'on crée de
l'excédent et on va vous faire vivre
avec les minima sociaux c'est pas
possible c'est pas entendable
politiquement et démocratiquement
vous avez commencé à ébaucher quelques
pistes justement pour parler à ces
territoires qui peuvent se sentir
relégué tenu à l'écart de la république
qu'elle serait justement comment on fait
pour le pont leur parler moi je crois
que globalement enfin notamment
vis-à-vis des territoires dont ladite
france périphérique mais toujours des
gars comme ça moi je pense qu'il ya il
ya un message de comment dire une forme
de pédagogie du changement parce que
j'ai encore une fois je pense que ce qui
fait ce qui les déstabilise
c'est le fait de ne plus retrouver de
repères c'est la fin d'un certain ordre
territoriales qu'est ce qui fait que les
villes moyennes souffre etc
c'est que voilà elle était installée
chef lieu d'un bassin de vie et c est
que les gens eux mêmes ont détruit sa
ont détruit sa avec les commerces de
périphérie etc et donc du coup c'est
comment on redonne de la lisibilité aux
territoires dans lesquels chacun vis et
comment on adresse un message de
confiance à ces territoires et puis
deuxièmement ce que je disais tout à
l'heure sur la différenciation moi je
pense qu on peut pas traiter par tous
cette question de la même manière
respect je pense qu'il ya un certain
nombre de notamment d'or dans ces
territoires ruraux des villes moyennes
je reprends la question de la france de
l'est j'insiste là dessus pour moi la
première fracture c est quoi la france
de l'est on n'a pas eu le courage dans
les politiques publiques de dire que y'a
un savant de territoires aujourd'hui
dont les où les gens sont partis ou en
tout cas une pâte ou partie de la
population s'en va et où du coup la
l'espèce de représentations dominantes
qu'un territoire qui va bien c'est un
territoire qui se développe il ya de la
croissance etc
bah c'est pas nécessairement vrai
partout et compte d'une certaine manière
qu'on peut vivre heureux et moins
nombreux j'irai à charleville mézières
ou à bar-le-duc et donc du coup que que
par exemple l'action publique les
services publics organisent un retrait
en bon ordre
c'est le maire de chalon comme on dit
maintenant châlons-en-champagne qui le
dit et qui nous a paru me semble assez
lucide qui dit voilà moi je dans les dix
ans qui viennent avec la fin de l'armée
etc
je vais devoir fermer dix écoles et bien
au lieu de le faire contre un effort et
forcé henry en catimini
j'assume et j'ai un plan et je fais une
chanson à accompagner le changement
voilà et là dessus il me semble que les
politiques sont mais manque de courage
quoi d'une certaine manière on va
entendre on va dire partout la même
chose quoi vous avez droit au
développement etc
non il ya aujourd'hui des territoires
qui sont des territoires qui sont un peu
en situation de gl etc et qui peut-être
redéveloppement dans 20 ans quand on dit
quand on voit le massif central massif
central perdre et de la population
depuis dix ans il en gagne bon il faut
assumer ses cycles de vie dans les
territoires et avoir des politiques
publiques
pragmatique rapidement et pour conclure
stéphane lauzon steak justement sur les
intentions de vote que vous vous
commencé à sonder pour le second tour
ces questions de cette france multi
fracturé sont très présentes dans les
motivations des électeurs mais les
principales motivations des français et
d'ailleurs c'est et ce sera encore plus
le cas dans l'entre-deux-tours qu'avant
le premier tour toutes les
problématiques sociales sont au cadeau
au coeur des attentes des français
marine le pen a parlé jean luc mélenchon
on a parlé d'autres candidats aussi s'il
n'y avait pas que deux évidemment quand
on demande aux français qu est-ce qui
comptera le plus au moment du choix de
vote dans dix jours maintenant c'est la
défense du pouvoir d'achat la réduction
des inégalités sociales qui arrive avant
le terrorisme l'insécurité c'est à dire
les thèmes qui indépendamment de ce qui
s'est passé sur les choses et dire qu'il
ya quelques jours c'est à dire les
thèmes majeurs qui ont fait l'actualité
ces dernières années sont relégués en
troisième quatrième cinquième position
pouvoir d'achat réduction des inégalités
sociales et évidemment lutte contre le
chômage